why do you feel that right now is the
right time in your career to take this
step and join the world of celebrity big
brother
i think after spending almost two years
at home with my family giving them so
much extra attention being able to put
so much effort into my business
being able to get away a little bit and
step away from my phone step away from
social media
and just be present
is huge
and as a celebrity you might be
accustomed to people watching your every
move and you know feeling like you live
under a microscope but are you ready for
the public to see you in a different
light and to be watching you 24 7.
you know i'm looking forward to people
seeing all my different sides um
the good the bad and the ugly i know
when i'm watching television or if i'm
watching anybody
i don't like to just see one side of
anyone i want to see the whole person so
i'm looking forward to showing myself
i love that and a follow-up to that so
what part of yourself are you maybe most
nervous or scared or embarrassed for the
public to see
um i think something i've worked on my
entire life um
that i'm trying
hard to overcome is caring what other
people think
and
you know i'm hoping that i will have the
confidence to be able to go into this
and stay strong the entire time and not
get super paranoid
but i you know i've seen
very strong individuals crumble under
pressure so i am uh
well surely you're gonna do great and um
who who would you not want to see walk
through the doors of celebrity big
brother and again it can be a type of
person or a specific person however you
want to answer
i kind of hope that
everyone that walks into celebrity big
brother is a fresh face to me that i
have never met before because i think
it's even more fun to form those brand
new relationships than
ones that have already formed themselves
you